okay so a manchester united
uh player aaron juan bisaka
uh his girlfriend dumped him recently
because
his side chick came out and basically
aired out all of his dirty laundry
saying that she's been
[ __ ] him on the low and he has a baby
coming out with a third woman
and they did this right there yes this
is a us
model um this is the side piece that's
his girlfriend her name's rihanna
and we are now waiting to figure out who
the third person is
because he's got another side chick yeah
the other side chick is pregnant and he
does not want the child
his ads are he plays for man united
mm-hmm women
she's not going anywhere he makes money
he does he's he's like your premier
league player you don't make money
what does he make they get they're the
highest paid the highest i think he just
got a deal for
55 million euros
would be for one year right like more
than like a baseball player
yeah they're the premier league sport
that makes the most money yes are you
serious
he looks like a good guy keep a clean
haircut he looks like he
looks like a good guy he looks she has
also been linked to
another player on his team as well as
the ra a rapper i think playboy cardi
who got
who uh iggy azalea baby uh daddy yeah i
think it's
that one it's one of the little rappers
she had a child she had a baby boy
really yeah
your famous dude who's the daddy uh
playboy cardi party
playboy there's so many people when she
was with uh swaggy p
yeah yeah yeah and then that and then uh
russell yeah oh wait no she dated sway
lee
sway lee oh that's who she has a baby
with from ray schwermann
uh no uh the side chick was also [ __ ]
with sway lee
damn i got a golden scene
yeah she just like when listen hashtag
bad girl
bad girl and they're always happy
hashtag
i'm looking at that i'm looking at that
i'm looking at that
look how bad she is they should have put
the baby mama first and then that one
they did that dirty they did the baby
look at the picture they chose of her
she looked like she's getting ready to
say something
is that this is a wholesome photo the
other one is that's not even she looks
like she's about to talk
wait time let's give her let's give her
the benefit of doubt can we go to the
instagram page that's all i want to know
don't don't go the side pieces i just
yeah i'm not going to i cannot stop it
so bad yeah
it's not fair anymore let's see what the
baby mom look like and then i'm off it
she don't have an instagram oh she
probably uh let's see if this works
she'll probably put on private now
i think that's very um but private okay
okay cool look at her
yeah they could have got it they gotta
gotta got a better man that's messed up
yeah they're gonna do the side piece
is that wait there's a better one oh
gosh i mean she's not bad looking she's
[ __ ] trying man
yeah yeah you gonna roll her she's
[ __ ] trying let that man live fathers
be good to your daughters
is what it roots back to your bubble gum
tongue girl
oh that's her when she was younger
probably again she's [ __ ] trying
you can't deal with it no i'm being cool
man
it's a little tough in the streets oh
gosh hashtag good guy
he has 55 million euros in his pocket
thank god dick
thank you the only mistake he made is he
got a chick pregnant he should have
strapped up
that's the only mistake he made you're
making fifty percent he got the side
piece pregnant no he got the side
side side side side side he got side
side piece
have a family with girl and then gets
the
side piece squared pregnant you know
yeah god
side p squared five p squared
i was like you got to apologize that
[ __ ] oh my god much love to her though
yeah i just loved you
when i got off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son